quand est-ce que vous avez pleuré pour
la dernière fois Bernard
très en forme Bernard juvénile
les trucs
un jour je vous le dirai des produits un
truc et puis je vous dirai si vous
voulez les mêmes
c'est cher
Bernard c'est ça voilà en tout cas ça
marche
75 regarde 75 ans
bon alors Bernard d'abord merci d'être
là vous n'avez rien à vendre et vous
êtes là par solidarité pour tout le
monde en parle parce que c'est
l'avant-dernière émission exactement
il a rien à vendre
30000 euros en équipe dans sa loge je te
signale que personne ne me les a donné
son nom de jardin non mais c'est vrai
franchement ça me fait vraiment plaisir
parce que parce que c'est une émission
qui va manquer beaucoup et donc je suis
content de venir avec vous de à
l'occasion d'un de ces dernières années
voilà merci alors bien sûr on va parler
politique mais on va commencer avec le
foot avec le Mondial avec les Bleus
[Musique]
alors Bernard vous expliquez comment
cette métamorphose des Bleus dans le
match contre l'Espagne
il y a plein de raisons mais on va on va
essayer de sortir les essentiels la
première et la plus importante c'est le
changement total de psychologie et de
motivation quand on rencontre le Togo la
Corée même la Suisse les Français ont
bosse dire ils se le disent il faut
gagner on va mettre tout notre cœur on
va mettre tout notre énergie ils font
appel à ce qu'on appelle la motivation
volontaire celle qui dépendent sa
volonté quand tu rencontres l'Espagne et
que il s'agit de passer un cap et
surtout de remettre des pendules à
l'heure là c'est tu fais appel à la
motivation inconsciente celle qui te
fait courir le 100 mètres parce que ton
gosse se noie hein la vraie différence
c'est ça s'éclate ils font ils font
appel à des ressources que seul la
volonté ne peut pas te donner alors
quand on sait qu'un être humain utilise
à peine la moitié de ses potentialités
car sur un match comme ça tu obtiens des
trucs bon alors ensuite l'Espagne eux
ont vécu le contraire on aura mis la
tête comme ça c'est les futurs champions
du monde ce qui fait que malgré
l'ouverture du score qui aurait pu leur
permettre de temporiser un peu de jouer
les malins de rester derrière et vas-y
on continue on continue et ils nous ont
donné des boulevards derrière que les
Français ont bien sûr exploités c'est
énorme voilà c'est énorme parce que on a
vu ce que ça a généré chez les gens
c'est inimaginable c'est une belle
démonstration de ce que les gens sont
capables de faire lorsqu'on leur offre
un événement qui les rend tribulatoire
les gens
incroyable je sais pas si tu as vu dans
les rues partout c'était une c'était un
bonheur exprimé sans limite et qu'on
voit pas dans les autres dans d'autres
formes d'existants parce que le sport
est en particulier le football moi je
vois jamais des gens qui se connaissent
pas dans la rue qui s'embrassent etc
c'est la grande quartier
c'est des boîtes privées oui
alors Bernard cette émission est
enregistrée exceptionnellement avant en
France Brésil on est jeudi soir donc tu
vas me donner un pronostic
et le match vient de finir c'est
horrible objectivement je ne
peux que te dire là ce qui va se passer
sûrement et te dire je souhaite
tellement j'ai tellement envie qu'on
gagne que je te fais pas de pronostic je
te fais que mon souhait ouais mais j'ai
vraiment la trouille j'ai vraiment peur
parce que réellement sur le papier
autant il y a pas une autre équipe
franchement il y a pas une autre équipe
qui nous est supérieure je dis bien sur
le papier sur le papier le Brésil nous
est supérieur alors maintenant est-ce
que cette espèce de confiance qu'on
vient de prendre cette espèce de de
volonté de ne rien avoir à faire parce
que maintenant ils ont fait l'essentiel
on est en quart de finale contre le
Brésil celui qui gagne là sera du
rabattre le fait que l'arbitre soit
espagnol
connerie pour nous difficile forcément
il va se venger
moi je pense que il y aura forcément à
dire sur l'arbitrage malheureusement tu
en sais quoi comme temps là parce que
c'est le coucher du soleil c'est quoi
chante elle a tombé du jour
que non
tu te connais pas les saisons la nature
tout ça tu connais pas c'est un merle la
merde
c'est un con j'en ai un dans mon jardin
il siffle déjà de Moro
tous les jours moi je
finisations dans le procès des contes de
l'OM Bernard Tapie
et je me pense la même chose que quand
elle s'adressait à moi
elles ont strictement aucun sens tu peux
pas condamner Robert loudreyfus pour un
but bien social dans son club dans
lequel il a mis 130 millions d'euros je
veux dire faut être
un peu schizophrène tu peux l'accuser
plein de choses éventuellement d'avoir
fait des contrats bidons d'avoir
arnaquer l'URSSAF que les joueurs et
trichés sur les impôts je suppose qu'il
doit y avoir dans le dossier des choses
mais ils l'ont pas retenu là-dessus donc
ça veut dire qu'il était coupable de
rien d'autre que ça et là c'est du
délire on peut pas reprocher un mec
d'avoir été puisque le délit d'abuste
bien c'est d'avoir porté tort à son
entreprise en gros en gros tu porteras
ton entreprise quand tu mets 150
millions d'euros dans les caisses pas
drôle de maso quand même donc ça tient
pas debout alors si on veut parler des
systèmes qui tournent autour du foot en
France je parle
tous les clubs ont recours au même
arnaques qui consiste à parfaire des
salaires concurrentiels avec les
étrangers qui payent moins d'impôts
voilà tout le problème est là quand un
joueur est sur le point de venir en
Angleterre en Espagne en Italie ou en
France il choisit un autre pays que le
nôtre parce qu'il est plus taxé alors
puisqu'on parlait tout à l'heure ça va
vous intéresser on parlait tout à
l'heure des pronostics et ben je vais
vous dire pourquoi la France est devenue
un petit pays de football l'Angleterre
tous les joueurs de l'équipe anglaise
jouent en Angleterre l'équipe sauf
Beckham l'Italie tous les joueurs de
l'équipe italienne journée l'Espagne
tous les joueurs d'Espagne joue en
Espagne les Allemands tous les joueurs
allemands jouent en Allemagne les
Français trois joueurs français jouent
en France voilà on a rejoint le peloton
des pays sous-développés c'est à cause
des impôts ils sont obligés
c'est globalement ces impôts c'est les
contrôles c'est l'URSSAF c'est un pays
qui devient un pays tellement pressurisé
que les gens ont envie d'aller ailleurs
et ceux qui se passe dans le football ne
vous faites pas d'illusions c'est comme
ça pour les artistes qui peuvent partir
ailleurs c'est comme ça pour tous les
autres sportifs de haut niveau c'est
comme ça pour les grands chercheurs
c'est comme ça pour les grands
ingénieurs et ça va finir par être comme
ça par pour tout le monde tu aurais pu
personne peut-être il y aura si il y
aura ceux qui veulent attendre des
autres leur salut personnel mais est-ce
que cette crise de confiance envers
l'équipe de France finalement ne traduit
pas ne reflètent pas une crise de
confiance du pays en lui-même les
Français sont très bizarres parce que il
y a un sondage sur la croyance le
bonheur etc qui m'a vachement épaté
c'est c'est ça dans challenge début de
l'année question êtes-vous plutôt
heureux plutôt malheureux 82 % des gens
plutôt heureux 9 deuxième question
pensez-vous que les Français sont plutôt
heureux malheureux ils pensent que 82 %
des Français sont malheurs
tu vois on est en schizophrénie totale
ça veut dire que toutes les nouvelles
toutes les infos qui sont ce qu'elles
sont on va pas reprocher aux journaux
télévisés de dire que il y a tant de
morts par le sida que il y a le tsunami
etc n'empêche que leur impression à eux
c'est de vivre au milieu d'une tempête
incroyable qui fait que tout le monde
doit être dans une merde noire tout le
monde doit souffrir et pas nous mais
c'est pas vrai je veux dire c'est un des
gros problèmes qui rend ce pays très
compliqué à gérer c'est pour ça que
c'est un pays où il y a un taux de
suicide très important c'est le plus
gros consommateur d'antidépresseurs au
monde la France vous savez ça c'est vrai
que au moment des trentes glorieuses on
a eu un modèle social très développé qui
était vraiment bien installé qui était
basé sur le partage sur le fait que tout
le monde doit profiter au moins en ce
qui concerne l'éducation la santé la
justice des progrès qui sont faits et
puis ils ont pris pour beaucoup
l'habitude d'être un peu sponsorisé un
peu assisté et quand il se sentent plus
dans cette situation de sécurité
beaucoup perdent les pédales on est
aussi un des pays où le divorce fait le
plus gravage et très des situations
dramatiques quand un couple sans moyens
divorce c'est des il y a des mecs qui
couchent dans la bagnole parce que ils
ont de quoi payer un appartement pas
deux évidemment heureusement on laisse
la femme dans l'appartement avec les
enfants et le mec il a pu un rond il
dort donc en dehors de la souffrance
affective il y a une souffrance
matérielle terrible mais il y avait un
sondage dans Le Nouvel Observateur dont
on parlait ici la semaine dernière déjà
moi qui m'étonne complètement c'est
êtes-vous favorable ou non à l'économie
de marché alors en Chine c'est 74% des
Chinois sont favorables à l'économie de
marché aux États-Unis c'est 71% dans les
grands pays européens c'est 65 66 % et
en France c'est 34%. alors est-ce que la
France est très en avance et elle a
compris que le capitalisme n'était pas
bien et elle est post capitaliste ou au
contraire est très en retard j'ai un
problème non mais d'abord il est
possible qu'il existe un système
beaucoup plus efficace plus généreux et
qui rend les gens plus heureux on le
connaît pas puisque pour l'instant on a
mis en opposition le marxisme
générer un socialiste plus une sociale
démocratie et puis la loi du marché bon
encore une fois la loi du marché pour
les gens c'est l'abandon d'une certaine
sécurité et d'une certaine protection un
peu la genre comme on est pays le plus
protégé forcément les Français sont les
plus opposés du marché ensuite il y a
l'interprétation qu'on se fait dans le
mot la loi du marché pour beaucoup la
loi du marché c'est la loi de la jungle
et il faut reconnaître que par certains
égards c'est un peu vrai alors est-ce
que le français est plus malin plus
impertinent plus rigoureux pour exiger
davantage c'est un peu tout ça
maintenant il faut que c'est français là
se disent que s'il existe une autre
technique une autre méthode c'est pas la
France qui pourra l'imposer seul parce
qu'elle fait 2% du monde la fin donc
dans un monde qui est entièrement soumis
à la loi du marché on est obligé de
l'adopter c'est du baratin alors on a
des mecs j'entends Besan snow j'entends
tous ces gens c'est bien c'est c'est
rafra ensemble les entendre dénoncer
mais ils font quoi ils font que dalle la
France c'est un peu le village d'Astérix
aujourd'hui non vous avez pas c'est
impression qu'il a dit les patrons faut
tous les virer on les remplacera par
quoi par d'autres patrons qui auront une
nouvelle hiérarchie toute la société est
basée sur une hiérarchie que tu tu mets
150 mecs sur une plage tu les laisses un
an et demi tu reviens il y a un patron
il y a deux adjoints puis il y a le
connard en bas parce qu'il veut rien
ou parce qu'il sait pas quoi
faire et la société doit être bien
organisée parce que celui qui est en bas
il a le droit aussi de vivre de pas être
piétiner d'être protégé qu'on lui pique
pas son du coup il baisse pas sa femme
il a le droit alors c'est là où la
société doit être organisée pour faire
face à la limite aux inégalités de la
hiérarchie mais une hiérarchie elle
existe dans les pays socialistes il y
avait une hiérarchie dans les pays
capitalistes il y a une hiérarchie la
France c'est un pays qui s'accommode mal
d'ailleurs c'est un pays acier
égalitariste la France bah on lui a fait
sa conception comme ça c'est logique
alors en tous les cas
qui a un moment donné ont eu envie de
franchir le pas est-ce que c'est
légitime quelque part oui quelque part
Louis parce que on n'a pas donné en tout
cas de gage sur la réalité de nos
convictions notre programmation etc par
conséquent on peut croire que on est
capable de séduire sur des éléments
d'appréciation qui justifie pas le vote
c'est pour ça que les électeurs font une
grande distinction entre la Côte d'Amour
avec des sondages extraordinaires un
Kushner et le vote le vote c'est une
opinion la côte d'amour c'est une humeur
ça nous ramène d'ailleurs à faire
attention aux sondages alors vous allez
pas revenir en politique Bernard mais
vous allez intervenir d'abord au nom des
3 millions de gens qui ont voté pour
vous tiens là c'est pas c'est pas du
sondage là c'est pas de l'humeur
et puis peut-être aussi au nom du Parti
radical de gauche non
c'est là que je suis parti parce que
c'est la philosophie radicale entre
parenthèses qui est peu développée on a
l'impression qu'il n'existe plus que
deux mais le radicalisme c'est justement
c'est faux souvenirs c'est Gambetta
c'est Mendes France c'est l'école le
public obligatoire c'est la séparation
de l'Église et de l'État enfin je veux
dire c'est des choses importantes le
dernier le radicalisme qui privilégie
l'homme plutôt que les systèmes qui met
l'homme au centre de préoccupations de
ces débats qui considère que un état une
nation un efforte que par l'addition de
ces valeurs individuelles elle reconnaît
donc la valeur individuelle comme un
élément d'appréciation mais à condition
que les intérêts individuels soient
compatibles avec l'intérêt collectif
normal en termes un peu plus simple ça
veut dire quoi chacun se démerde chacun
essaie d'être le meilleur on doit pas
envisager une égalité par le bas mais
face à la scolarité donc à
l'apprentissage face à la santé face à
la justice on doit tous être égaux le
chanceux le malchanceux l'intelligent le
con tout le monde c'est la République
c'est la République c'est la réponse
c'est ce qu'on appelle la République
alors en 2007 vous croyez vous à un
match Sarko Sego
il est pour l'instant il est il est plus
que probable est-ce que vous croyez que
les mecs comme langue comme Fabius comme
Strauss-Kahn j'ai 15 ans les mecs qui
sont là qui rame vous croyez qu'ils vont
laisser ces Golan Royal leur piquait non
seulement je crois le business mais
alors là pour le coup je comprends rien
à la stratégie du Parti socialiste rien
c'est le contraire justement de ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure du radicalisme
l'élection présidentielle c'est un
candidat ou une candidate qui se
présente dans les Français qui fait une
proposition qui dit voilà la société
telle que je l'imagine et qui
s'entourent des gens pour la mettre en
place le Parti socialiste commence à te
dire voilà le programme on se met tous
d'accord sur un programme donc on est
tous d'accord pour dire la même chose et
après comme un casting
comme un film un film tu fais le
scénario et après tu as le metteur en
scène commence à choisir les acteurs
mais c'est de la folie chaque scandale
socialiste à la candidature devrait
faire son programme
passer devant les militants pour que les
militants c'est vrai c'est vrai un homme
et un programme et non pas pour un homme
ou une femme sur un même programme c'est
ça qui les amène d'abord à dire
n'importe quoi tu as vu Ségolène est
toujours à 1000 kilomètres
or laissons Ségolène Royal vendent son
programme celui auquel elle croit si les
militants socialistes en veulent pas ils
peuvent préférer Strauss-Kahn qui ne
manque pas de qualité et qui manque pas
d'idées ou Fabius qui manque pas de
qualité qui manque pas d'idées et après
par la loi normale de respecter le vote
des militants tout le monde se mène et
le candidat et son programme plutôt que
ça alors ta Ségolène qui est pour on
sert un peu la vie le Parti socialiste
qui est non non on sert pas la vis tu as
Ségolène qui est pour le mariage non
déconne pas on est contre le mariage tu
comprends plus rien c'est du délire
Ségolène vous la connaissez bien elle
est sympa prêt elle parle de Blaire
mais faut pas vous faire d'illusions
elle est socialiste ah oui oui
vrai alors ceux qui aiment ça bah
allez-y les mecs et Sarkozy vous êtes
copain Bernard non plus non non je
l'aime bien ouais je le connais on se
connaît et lui aussi c'est un candidat
redoutable mais lui il est dans une
configuration qui est plus facile parce
que l'UMP c'est devenu son parti il est
à la fois prescripteur des idées de son
parti et récepteurs de ce que le son
parti propose autrement dit il va nous
faire une programmation clé en main de
ce qui ressent et des hommes qui vont le
souvenir pour le faire donc là il est
plus à l'aise pour aller devant les
électeurs que quelqu'un qui va défendre
un programme qui est pas le sien
donc je dirais que normalement on a plus
de chance alors c'est peut-être une
bonne ou mauvaise chose chaque Français
fera ce qu'il veut mais vous avez plus
de chance de voir Sarkozy faire ce qui
va dire qu'il va faire que les
socialistes que les socialistes parce
que lui il a voilà c'est son programme
et tu as vu que je pars reviens tu as eu
cette semaine oui dans la même semaine
on a quand même eu le président qui a
annoncé qui dira si les candidats au
premier trimestre 2007 et j'ose pas
qu'il nous dit officiellement ce qu'il a
pas arrêté de nous dire il faut quand
même dire que ça fait un an qu'il nous
dit retenez moi où j'y vais et si vous
m'appelez je vais y aller donc vous
rendez compte qu'on va peut-être
assister à une un autre France Brésil
quoi
à la limite ça va être de nouveau le
combat des chefs mais non j'ose pas je
crois qu'il se met en jeu en faisant ça
ouais il se met pas hors-jeu en étant
candidat il se met en jeu en annonçant
qu'il peut l'être si on va le chercher
parce qu'il aurait pu très bien ne pas
annoncer qu'il était candidat avant
qu'on le demande
et là il avait une légitimité quelque
part pourquoi d'abord parce que il croit
pas un instant que Ségolène Royal est
capable il dit pas qu'elle va pas gagner
il estime tout le monde sait qu'il a
considère pas capable d'être président
de la République deuxièmement il pense
que les communistes les vers les
extrêmes gauches etc il a à peu près le
seul à pouvoir faire la gauche plus rien
espèce de gauche plus rien donc s'il
avait été effectivement demandé sans
qu'ils disent
c'était crédible on met là il leur
demande qu'on l'appelle alors qu'on leur
demande pas je crois qu'il s'est
disqualifié tu vois que les gens lui en
veulent en plus de cette balade en 2002
quoi
non il lui en veulent pas de cette barre
en 2002 il a une attitude au contraire
honorable j'allais dire digne minimum
que tous les politiques devraient avoir
moi le jour où j'ai été mis hors la
politique pour les raisons vous savez je
me suis mis même si maintenant je suis
éligible je considère qu'on peut pas
dire bah tiens je suis fini je reviens
il a été porteur d'un échec terrible il
en a souffert terriblement il a eu le
seul comportement digne que tous les
hommes politiques n'auraient pas eu en
vouloir pour ça ah non il a été eu au
contraire exemplaire alors maintenant
Cindy attendez finalement je vais
peut-être revenir sur Zelda noir là ça
sent un peu le faisant des quand même
alors Bernard tapis vous serez candidat
de toute façon dans le film de Fabien
antoniante qui s'appelle le candidat
justement j'ai adoré ce mec c'est
rencontrer il m'a dit qu'est-ce que tu
prépares je lui dis une pièce comment
s'appelle le candidat il m'a dit non tu
fais un film avec moi hein il est
vraiment génial donc on va faire un film
ensemble à la rentrée là
j'ai bien aimé le son approche il a il a
déjà une bonne idée alors vous avez
déclaré j'ai connu la vie avec beaucoup
d'argent je la connais maintenant sans
je préfère la vie avec et ben ça vous
étonne pas tout est mieux c'est
vachement mieux c'est vachement mieux
parce que les gens essaient de mettre en
opposition
l'argent est le bonheur par exemple
évidemment si tu me dis tu préfères
riche ou en bonne santé ça suppose que
tu es riche et malade oui je préférais
pauvre en bonne santé mais t'es pas
obligé d'être malade parce que tu es
riche
tu as compris ouais donc en bonne santé
riche et en bonne santé pauvre c'est
mieux en bonne santé riche mais c'est
tout mieux arrêtez de déconner d'accord
non mais vous
non mais c'est mieux d'avoir de l'argent
vous dites maintenant je connais la vie
sans argent ça veut dire quoi
d'avoir un salaire qui correspond à un
salaire de cadre hein et pas plus non
puisque tout le reste c'est gaulé
non mais quoi que vous gagnez maintenant
et courbé qu'il était trop lourd de mon
condamné Roland
tu as eu deux ans de prison
il a récupéré 18 mois
qu'on donne à un type qui viole dans la
rue en gros il a dû faire des trucs
terribles et je crois pas qu'il est fait
non terrible vous l'aimez bien oui
j'aime beaucoup
on va faire une artiview
Bernard vous pensez à quoi en ce moment
là
je suis bien ouais
quand vous regardez le matin dans la
glace vous dites quoi Bernard
le seul moment où je me regarde dans la
glace au moment où je me rase et
franchement je me parle pas dans ce
moment-là pas comme ça
dans la journée ça m'arrive je suis en
bagnole tout je me dis allez vas-y mon
gars ils toront pas par exemple
vous auriez aimé ressembler à qui quand
vous étiez petit Bernard comme tout le
monde ça dépend de l'âge à quel âge pas
vers 12 ans là quand on commence à 12
ans
12 ans mais le ferrer mais le ferrer
parce qu'il sautait Audrey burn j'étais
fou d'elle ça se comprend votre plus
belle histoire d'amour
ça fait 32 ans qu'elle dure
c'est beau prendre
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les gens ont
perdu un peu le sens du couple quoi
c'est à compromis en difficulté il
divorce quoi c'est vrai oui mais il y a
des couples c'est vraiment un coup de
bol parce que
tu vois bien il y a des gens plein de
bonnes volonté on va pas se forcer quoi
c'est pas quelque chose qui te non mais
c'est un peu vouloir voilà la vérité
c'est qu'il faut quand même le vouloir
il faut dire je veux réussir et il y a
des passages difficiles et souvent on
s'aperçoit que si tu surmontes difficile
en y mettant un peu du sien hop tu
repars nous on a été vraiment vachement
bien pendant 20 ans sans aucun problème
puis on a commencé à rentrer dans
l'habitude et là dessus on a eu Sophie
et Sophie nous a redonné un coup
incroyable parce qu'on s'est retrouvé de
nouveau parent avec les problèmes d'un
enfant en bas âge etc et là tout va bien
ah ouais super
est-ce que vous seriez prêt à tout
quitter pour le grand invention demain
dans la rue vous tombez sur une gonzesse
mais fou d'amour ma femme j'ai tout
quitté pour elle elle est déjà fait j'ai
arrêté de bosser c'est-à-dire quand on
s'est connu on a arrêté l'un et l'autre
de bosser on a vécu sur nos économies et
on a vécu 9 mois on a rien fait d'autre
rien d'autre que manger dormir et Tagada
9 mois après il y a plus de thunes quand
est-ce que vous avez pleuré pour la
dernière fois Bernard
quand j'ai vu d'emballage j'avais pas
les 30000 euros promis
dans un trou c'est un chien
auriez quoi en vous si vous aviez une
baguette magique mais là de naissance
ouais
qu'est-ce que vous pourriez dire de plus
négatif sur vous
et tu crois pas qu'il en était saisi
comme ça sonne
moi j'ai été gâté quand même on m'a
retiré on m'a privé de mes droits
civiques on m'a privé de mes droits
parental on m'a interdit de sport on m'a
interdit de politique on m'int interdit
d'affaires on m'a dit maintenant refais
toi
l'authentique ils ont cru que j'allais
d'ailleurs pas me refaire jamais
il y a eu un moment vous êtes dit je
vais jamais y arriver à me refaire
ah ouais plusieurs fois
et justement si votre vie était à
refaire qu'est-ce que vous changeriez de
sexe
maintenant j'aimerais connaître femme tu
as envie de te faire attraper toi
vous seriez vous seriez un peu
c'est pour ça que je te dis ça
qu'avez-vous le plus envie d'épater dans
la vie à c'est un truc que j'ai jamais
aimé ça hein j'ai jamais aimé épater oh
Bernard j'ai donné deux exemples j'avais
un beau bateau jamais personne a pu
monter dessus voir une photo de
l'intérieur de mon bateau on n'était
jamais ailleurs que loin
il a été acheté par une femme on a vu
une chambre à coucher la salle à manger
les dîners
le pot de géranium sur l'arrière
non moi je sais pas c'est pas j'aime
bien j'aime bien surprendre j'aime bien
être aimé j'aime bien ça mais j'aime pas
épater alors deuxième exemple le bateau
c'était le premier c'est quoi le
deuxième exemple mon ma maison d'accord
personne est rentrée faire des photos
dans ma maison
il a piqué les meubles
qu'est-ce que vous feriez si vous restez
24 heures à vivre un crédit
je crois que je réglerai quelques
comptes quand même juste avant de partir
il y en a quelques-uns qui sont pas
soldés encore deux trois bourbiers il y
a deux trois il y a une tournée à faire
est-ce que vous avez déjà pensé au
suicide oui
une fois en prison non non c'était
dehors
et grâce à la
à la présence d'esprit de ma femme ça
c'est ça c'est pas fait
qu'est-ce que la vie vous a appris
Bernard Tapie qui le pire est jamais
certain
comment aimeriez-vous mourir
je m'en fous vraiment
enterré incinéré après vivant comment tu
sens le truc ah non non
j'ai pas peur de ça du tout je suis
croyant
j'ai pas fait trop de mal contrairement
à ce qu'on a dit il y a pas tellement de
gens qu'on souffert et donc à la fin du
parcours je pense qu'il me dira allez
viens il était temps que tu arrives
1 2 3 4
c'est pas truqué
le doigt avant de venir comment tu t'es
coupé le doigt j'ai voulu remettre une
applique qui était pas droite
vous n'allez plus en prison vous
repassez pas la case départ et vous
toucherez sans entretien d'euros alors
tu en es où justement avec cette affaire
des 135 millions là aujourd'hui je viens
d'apprendre que
la Cour de cassation qui devait se
prononcer en juillet début juillet
le premier président a fait un
communiqué pour dire que c'était reporté
en séance plénière au début octobre donc
ça veut dire que tu as gagné en première
instance tu as gagné en appel là c'est
en cassation si en cassation tu gagnes
on t'a gagné tu récupères le pognon et
si tu perds c'est rejet entièrement
depuis le début non non c'est la ça
repasse dans une chambre d'appel alors
on appelle alors on revient à l'appel
mais ça fera là donc je savais à faire
trois mois de plus donc ça fera 12 ans
et 6 mois c'est les jours sans fin c'est
sans fin 12 ans et 6 mois
ça ira dans dans les poches de l'état et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu